Film Courage: When you finish a screenplay,
what do you do?
Jeffrey Reddick, horror screenwriter/producer:
That’s a good question.
I usually take a nap, seriously.
No I do, I do.
I don’t do anything crazy like celebrate.
I get very happy and I’m like yes and I
send it off and I usually go take a nap (especially
when I’m in that last stretch where something
is either due or I’m almost done that’s
where I get a little, super where I am
going back through everything and I’m paginating
the pages.
And one of the tricks I learned is to try
to have the last line of it on the page is
something where they have literally make it
a page turner where they have to the page
to see what the next page is going to be.
That was a trick I learned from a friend of
mine.
And so I try to go through and make sure that
unless it’s the very end of a really great
scene that every end of every page is something
where you have to flip the page to at least
finish it because if you get them over to
the next page they’re probably going to
keep reading.
It’s like if you stop them at the end of
the page with something like blah they may
not turn the next page.
So after I’ve worked on the script itself
I then do those little mind-gamey things so
to make sure it’s a page turner.
By the time I’m ready to send it off I have
to go back through it one more time and then
I take a nap because I’ve wore myself out.
Film Courage: Also to is a sense of accomplishment
where you feel “Okay, I can rest now.”
Because I’m sure up until a certain deadline
there might be a lot of sleepless nights or
maybe not?
Jeffrey: It’s sleepless nights and it’s
stress but when I finish something there is
definitely a sense of accomplishment where
you’re like “Yes!”
Especially if you know it’s good.
If you’re not sure then it’s kind of like
… send (with your fingers crossed).
But I’m still going to take a nap.
But when you feel like you really nailed it,
it’s good but that’s again the interesting
thing about the business is that you can go
a script that you’re a hundred percent confident
in and your producer loved it but one person
at the studio reads it and is like “Meh?”
And you’re like “Ahhh…”
So again it’s a roller coaster ride.
That’s why again I’m very big on people
doing their own content and trying to do your
own content because that’s if you really
want to ensure if something gets made done
the way you write it, that’s the best way
to do it.
It’s very, very gratifying when you type
The End and you mean it and you can hit send
to whoever you have to send the script over
to so you definitely feel like “Good job.”
Film Courage: So if you’re not a writer-for-hire
for something and it’s your own passion
project and you finish it then what’s your
process?
Jeffrey: Then I usually try to send it to
my agent or manager to look at and then figure
out what places to send it to.
Or now what I started doing because I’m
getting more into producing my own stuff is
connecting with some people that I think have
access to invest, more of the business side
of it.
Like “Okay, this might be good for this
company, these companies, so let’s try to
attach somebody.”
Now I’ve gotten more business-minded in
the last couple of years especially because
I’d love to someday be at the point where
I’m running my own assistants and we can
read a bunch of scripts too and make a whole
bunch of movies but right now it’s like
I have some good stories that I want to tell
and I’m like I’ve got to maximize the
chance to get those made so that means if
it’s something that I’ve written on my
own, a lot of times now I’m going out and
looking for independent financing as opposed
to trying to get it set up somewhere.
So that’s been a fun learning experience
in the last year.